we're constantly talking to our children
about sex
TV is constantly talking to your
children about sex the covers of all the
trashy tabloids and the supermarket are
talking to your kids about sex we need
to let our kids we need to inform them
about the realities of sex because the
unrealities of sex on television and
film tabloids on the internet and
pornography are coming at them all the
time and you need to explain to them how
sex really works and how love really
works because if you let just the mass
media shape their attitudes and their
ideas can really warp them
age-appropriate you need to talk to kids
about sex I say this all having screwed
up the birds-and-the-bees talk myself
you know when our son was curious when
where babies came from we explained and
we had the sex talk at a you know
appropriate time and then one day he
came down to the kitchen and jumped up
on the kitchen counter looked at me and
narrowed his eyes and said you and daddy
have sex for no reason because you can't
make a baby and it again I go fuck
uh-huh
we had left out sex for pleasure when we
talked to him about the birds and the
bees and everybody does right and sex
for pleasure is 99.99% of the sex that
everybody is having and a given weekend
it's the only kind of sex gay people can
have but it's the only kind of sex
straight people have most of their lives
great people have a handful of children
and a lot of sex gay sex happens for all
the same reasons that straight sex
happens for except those handfuls of
times when the straight people are
trying to make a baby and we left that
out that sex is about pleasure and
intimacy and a personal connection and
cementing a bond and love and sex exist
so that you can you know live with
somebody for decades and decades and not
kill them it's an important part of it
you know there's certain times I'm you
know fighting with my boyfriend
relationships involve a lot of conflict
and I'm looking at him and the front of
my brain my higher intelligence is
saying now is the time to wrap your
hands around his throat and kill him and
my reptile brain is going no no no you
need
throughout for later that throat is many
good things to you so please don't kill
him